everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today I'm gonna be
covering my favorite topic in chess and
that is chess gambits ever since I was a
kid I loved playing chess game it could
be because gambit was my favorite
character on x-men cartoons or it could
be because I loved giving up material in
chess and then almost turning it into a
puzzle how can I give up material and
then find an advantage for my setup I
just love that so I made a video on my
top eight favorite chess game it's now
it is subjective so I want to give you
the criteria that went into it the first
one is how often you're gonna get to
play this game but there's some obscure
game it's that people like out there but
they just never come up I like game it's
that I can play anytime I want to
because the positions are always coming
up in my chess games and the next one is
how much fun the game it is I like to
look at my opponents face and just have
them confused trying to figure out why
in the world I would play the moves that
I'm making so hopefully you guys enjoy
this video if you have other gamuts that
you really really like feel free to put
those in the comment section below but I
think you'll find some on this video
that you may not be familiar with also
for the first time in ten years we're
gonna try this out if you wouldn't mind
subscribing to the channel if you're not
already and hitting the like button
again first time in ten years hundreds
of videos never asked for people to do
that but just curious to see how many
people we can actually like this video
and subscribe to the channel so without
further adieu hopefully you guys enjoy
my top eight chess gambits
coming in at number eight we have the
Schliemann game but what starts out with
the right Lopez with e4 e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop to b5 and usually in
the right Lopez likes looking to play a6
looking to play Knight to f6
but in the Schliemann game it black
plays f5 says I'm gonna completely
disrupt everything white is looking to
do I can't continue in the same game
plan how did they really continue from
here it looks logical to take this
material that's completely fine it's
what black wants black and now push
forward with E for this Knight can't
come to g5 or h4 it's just gonna fall to
the queen that comes back to g1 that
feels really weird all of a sudden you
have d1 the bishop can take here on f5
it's all in all white doesn't have
nearly the setup that they were hoping
for in the Rye Lopez all of a sudden
black is really looking to dominate the
center of the board so if you haven't
played your Schliemann game it is a fun
way to counter the Rye Lopez
coming in at number seven we have the
Tennyson game but what starts out with E
for d5 and if I like anytime black plays
this they almost first sure know that
White's gonna take here on d5 but what
if they don't what if they play the
tennis and gave it which is Knight to f3
and says hey I don't mind if you take
this I'm gonna bring my knight up here
to g5 attacking this now they could just
say I'm gonna completely ignore that I
don't know what you're up to
great you can just come back here and
take with your knight if they try to
hold on to this well then you can start
to get pretty aggressive with Bishop to
c4 you can see the knight on d5 is
already attacking this square here on f7
which is extremely weak it's only
defended by the king here that's on e8
right now so a lot of strong attacks
they can defend it in many different
ways but white has a strong attack
depending on where they move so that is
the Tennyson game it always catches your
opponent off guard
coming at number six we have at a
Halloween game but one of my favorites
has a kid because it was the first game
that I played where I wasn't just giving
up a pawn I was actually giving up a
knight a minor piece so that always
intrigued me starts out with E 4 E 5 and
then f3 knight c6 then usually gets into
the four Knights game with Knight to c3
Knight f6 and then the Knight takes here
on e5 so exchanging a knight for a pawn
after the Knight takes then white starts
the offensive attack in the center of
the board pawn to d4 usually the night
it's gonna come back to c6 and it can
just continue to attack knight down here
to e5 pawn pushes forward really just
needs to come back here to g6 y can push
forward again Knight moves back here so
you can see black is up material but
white has a strong presence in the
center of the board if you haven't ever
played the Halloween gamete I highly
recommend I always fun to give up a
minor piece early on and then see if you
can turn that into a win
coming at number five we have the
Colorado gambit which starts out with E
for Knight to c6 and then Knight to f3
or it could also start with the knight
coming here to f3 first and then the
pawn here to e4 but either way it's
blacks move and the common response is
not what we're gonna play that would be
something like e5 Bishop down here to b5
this gets into the right Lopez but you
could always play the Schliemann gambit
in this if you wanted to but the color
out a game it says we're not even
playing Eve 5 we're just gonna
immediately attack here with f5 so very
similar to the Schliemann game it
looking to attack the center of the
board with the F pawn knowing that later
on you could cast on the King side you
can have your rook here on the semi-open
F file at some point Black has a lot of
strong attacks but they never expect you
to play this f5 now if they push forward
that's gonna be completely fine you can
start to disrupt the center of the bore
this opens up lines for your
LightSquared Bishop to get involved into
the game to take away their center pawn
here if they don't take maybe they get
their Bishop involved into the game then
you can just take their pawn if they
decide to go ahead and take well you can
just start to push in the center of the
board they've lost their Center pawns
you have a lot of attacking lines in the
Colorado game a definitely a good way to
disrupt your opponent when they start
out with E for Knight f3
coming at number four we have the Jerome
game it one of the more aggressive lines
that you'll see in this video series but
it starts out with E 4 E 5 and then f3
Knight to c6 you can tell what type of
games I play a lot of but instead of
they're just coming to b5 the Bishop's
going to come to c4 and most common
response is Bishop down here to c5 and
here's where things start to get tricky
the Bishop takes on F seven sacrifices
material and said I'm gonna give up my
Bishop for the pond so that I can start
to attack my opponents key now they
don't have to take the bishop but if
they don't that's just weird like you
should tell them to go ahead and take it
because they're gonna lose if they don't
take it but once they take it that
allows you to continue with the drum
game it and that says I haven't given up
enough material I'm gonna give up more
I'm gonna go ahead and play Knight to e5
this is check they pretty much have to
take with their Knight there's really no
real reason for them not to but after
they take with their night then Queen to
h5 and this is where the fun begins so
you can tell you give it up a lot of
material already at night and a bishop
but you have a strong attack there Kings
out in the center and you can start to
have some fun so if you haven't played
the drum game it I highly recommend it
coming at number 3 we have the steinitz
gambit which starts out with e4 e5 but
changing things up a little bit and that
is Knight to c3 most players just assume
White's gonna if they're gonna play a
knight come here to f3 but you don't
always have to you can play Knight to c3
and many times bike will just respond
with the same thing they'll go ahead and
play Knight to c6 I'll just Mary am not
exactly sure what you're doing and then
you can play f4 and this is where the
fun begins in the Steinitz game but
after they take here why it's really
just looking to dominate the center of
the board that's the main theme of this
opening but after d4 well I can start to
attack and play Queen down here to h4
and the King has to come to e2 you're
not gonna play pawn here because then
after the pond takes you're just giving
up more material on the pawn can't
recapture cuz the rook is gonna fall the
King has to come here to e2 and this
looks really awkward because the King is
blocking this LightSquared bishop and it
could no longer Castle to either side of
the board but it actually works out
extremely well for white the Knights
gonna come here to have to be pretty
soon chase the Queen around while
Black's busy moving his queen not doing
anything productive White's over here
developing the center of the board
getting all those minor pieces developed
into the game chasing black around it's
a very very good gambit and white has a
lot of attacking lines that may not look
like it when you just look at this board
setup right here
coming into number 2 we have the cochran
gamut and that starts out with E 4 E 5
don't judge me I'll play a lot of efore
games and there's a lot of game it's to
come out of this Knight to f3 and then
Knight to f6 so sometimes black will try
the petrov defense which is this right
here thinking that they can catch white
off-guard and it normally continues with
Knight to e5 and then the pend comes to
d6 and the knight comes back to f3 and
then the knight takes here and then we
continue on the board but what if white
says not today
I'm not going to retreat I'm gonna
continue my attack and that's exactly
what the Cochran game it does and the
knight takes here on f7 now after the
King takes if they don't take that's
just weird you're gonna take this rook
you're gonna take the Queen bad things
are gonna happen so after they take here
then White's gonna play d4 because this
opens up all the lines the Queen is on
line the LightSquared Bishop saan line
now the darks for bishops on line it's
also giving up another pot of material
if they want to take that that's fine
Queen can come over here to h5 this
square is no longer protected attacking
the King the Queen can swing over here
depending on where the King goes to can
get both the bishops involved things are
extremely bad for black definitely a fun
way any time someone tries to Petrov
this is always my go-to because it
catches them off guard they just always
expect the the knight to come back here
to f3 but then just to see them after I
played Knight to f7 and realized that
they're gonna get their King chased
around the board for the rest of the
game
coming in at number one we have the
musio gambit and yes it derives from the
Kings gambit but I feel like it was
almost cheating to have number one be in
the Kings gambit because I always do
videos on the Kings gambit most of you
know that that is my favorite opening
but this is a specific variation in the
Kings gambit that is my favorite
any time I get the opportunity to play
it I absolutely will
the King's game it for those not
familiar a 45 F 4 and then after the
pawn recaptures Knight to f3
now the musio game it really needs them
to come down with g5 which many times
they will their start to attack on the
Kings side of the board this protects
this pawn and start to add pressure on
this g4 square sometimes in the King's
gambit you'll play h4 so that then when
they come down here to g4 you you have
an outpost you can start to attack get
your LightSquared Bishop over here to c4
and attack the f7 Square but that's not
what the musio game that's looking to do
says hey I don't even care about that
I'm just gonna start developing my
material and so if they push forward
this is where it gets even more fun
because you're just gonna cast on the
king's head you don't even care about
the knight after they take with their
pawn you're gonna recapture with your
Queens you can see you have your most
powerful piece involved into the game
you have your bishop here eyeing down on
their weakest square you've already
castled you have a rook open on the
semi-open file
they can't castle on the King side and
have King safety their chief pawn is
gone they have no pieces developed you
can easily push forward here with a d4
and get your darks Forbush involvement
of the game so anytime I play the King's
gambit although I don't know what my
opponent's going to do the musio gambit
is my number one go-to if I have the
opportunity to play it so that is my
list of top eight chess gambits
hopefully guys and enjoyed this video
again if you haven't already please
subscribe to the video and if you liked
this list and want to see more feel free
to give me a thumbs up also if you have
a gambit that I did not cover that you
want to let people know about that you
enjoy playing feel free to leave that in
the comments if you have other chest
video ideas you can always contact me at
email the chess website at gmail.com
that is the best way to reach out to me
but
you guys so much for watching and I will
see you in the next video